[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the wheel of time episode six the flame
of tarvalon like always in the comments
if you're going to talk about the books
please make sure you are talking about
stuff we've already seen in the show
nothing in the future please no spoilers
from the books only stuff we've already
seen that's in the books that's in the
show i have not read the book so please
keep that a mystery for everybody so we
can still enjoy it as new so this
episode we got to meet this new
character of su-1 and we get a little
glimpse into her backstory here and she
was channeling at this very young age
untying this knot we see of her poor
father the fisherman so she's got this
bit of traumatic moment in her life
where her house burns down she has to
leave her dad go to the white tower and
there's some symbol there book readers
probably will know what it is that is
marked on the burnt area i wonder who
did it but it will be interesting when
that comes back around for the character
of sue on so when we get a glimpse of
her in present day she is played by
sophie okun nedu who was actually
nominated for an oscar for supporting
actress in hotel rwanda in 2004 but she
really does a good job in this role and
it's a big role because she has to do a
lot of facial expressions and reactions
that mean many things and she pulls it
off throughout this episode i also love
the set here i love the hall that
they're in and i love that it's circular
again just going to the theme of the
show about the wheel and the whole show
is circular and it gives the
cinematographer a little you know room
to play with here and do things in
circular motion which he does a lot
through this episode and it was really
cool looking i think i love the height
of this haul and i also love all the
colors we're seeing by the different iso
dye and they can kind of really show it
off here on this set i thought it looked
really good now logan has been great in
this show so far i think he's a fan
favorite it was nice to see him again
here but he's kind of put in front of
suwon and she's like why is he chained
gentled he is no threat i actually love
this line again just reminding people
who don't read the books all these
different kind of rules of the world and
i like that he gets to boast here saying
he faced nine eyes to die and still
staked the green won't say the word here
to the wall but he also has interesting
information that i said i the further
they get from the tower he claims you
are weaker than you ever been so i
thought that was interesting too but you
see suwon won't give him the benefit of
just giving him death she wants him to
suffer in his ways and his madness and
wants him to serve as an example to all
other false dragons and men who dared to
channel it's better to watch this
episode twice this is definitely a watch
twice episode especially having read the
books because it will all seem so
different once you know the whole twist
about suwon and maureen being in on
their plan together so you're kind of
seeing how much of this is an act and
also how much leandron has a good sense
of something's up you know and how she's
on to them and in this episode leandron
really really lines up with the
character of draco malfoy to me and how
accusatory she is you know just being
nosy saying nasty things
but you love that didn't you potter
famous harry potter can't even go to a
bookshop without making the front page
but she's not far off from what's
actually going on which is interesting
so i like again having leandro on the
screen as much as they have i think
she's an interesting character and a
nice combative force to moraine and you
see leandron even talks back to suwon
and saying things like doesn't question
moraine because mother was once blue
herself i really like lines like that
and again it just reminds me so much of
draco coupon coil
you're absolutely right
saint potter so my favorite scene this
episode which i thought was awesome was
when moraine shows up to matt and takes
the darkness from shadow city
out of him and puts it into the cursed
blade and like i mentioned cgi hasn't
been great in the show but i'm sure
season two will be way better so i'm not
gonna obsess over that but i really like
the scene it felt like i was watching a
scene from the exorcist it was like this
really really awesome scene and i am a
little confused though i'm pretty sure
she's gentling there but they don't say
it in the episode and i'm confused
because i wouldn't just say she's gently
because rand seem oddly like nice to her
after not asking questions because he
knows what would happen too mad if he
was gentle so i was a little confused
with that so if people can clear that up
if she was actually gently him there if
it was just some other power i would uh
love to know that because it was not
clear to me but the conversation with
moraine and rand here is interesting
because she says you know he still could
be the dragon because he has incredible
strength because he wasn't already fully
consumed by that darkness from the blade
so that's interesting i like that you
know every character in this group from
two rivers they're giving you little
teases at them being the dragon and that
this episode opens the possibility of
them all being like a separate dragon
entity which is kind of cool and you see
here moraine you know goes to nineveh
and is like why didn't you tell me what
was happening with matt you could have
had him killed and she says if wisdom is
the title you claim i suggest you start
using some whoa that is like mic drop
moment for moraine ouch so meigen who is
this blue leader has this nice spa day
with moraine i love this hot tub by the
way i this is my dream wonder something
about me everything i do in life is to
one day be able to have a beautiful
indoor hot tub it's what gets me up in
the morning and this hot tub looked
amazing so shout out hot tubs and fellow
people have that dream but you know
meigen wants moraine to stay in the
tower so she can travel to find the ship
that was missing so this is gonna be the
reason why moraine tells suwon later on
that she wants to be exiled as the
punishment and now quickly maybe a
little too quickly pacing-wise for my
taste it's kind of felt abrupt but
moraine is told about it wayne and
parent arriving and wayne asked moraine
and matt about matt and rand and she
does not tell her she already saw them
and do what she did to matt so it's
interesting how private she's being
about everything like she's saying
everyone keep these secrets and she's
even saying that to aguain about her
telling her about perrin with this wolf
power like she's like people will kill
him so it's fascinating and this episode
put more in a better light to me as i
went on her true care for this group but
there's still gray there which we're
gonna get to i'm gonna point out a
couple things i thought was interesting
with her character and all in all the
character marine has been super
interesting rosamund pike is obviously
killing it but she's bringing that
complication where she's bringing so
much with her facial expressions and if
you like her if you can trust her if you
can't trust her so i like how they're
doing her character they've really put
such a nice detail to her so it was also
interesting with moraine was when she's
in her bedroom you know she's putting
her hair down she's taking off the blue
garments the jewelry it's the first time
we're not seeing her and her isodi state
here which that was really interesting
and of course it's when she's going to
the big reveal which we see her lover is
swan you know this is gonna be the thing
that's gonna set off people on imdb that
just troll and give one-star views to
things they say are woke so you know
there's gonna be huge fighting about
this episode but i think it's just
ridiculous i mean
who cares you know it's the decision of
the writers here and if it's good
storytelling if it's good relationship
building then so be it again it's not
the books it's a show it's different
medium here and it's gonna be a lot
different than the books but it's
interesting so moraine masked the bond
with lan here and she's like it's been
at least two years since she's done that
thought you need a welcome break and
he's like you're not safe here moraine
and i can't protect you if i can't feel
you which is really interesting stuff
especially for me i think this whole
masking concept is pretty cool they can
kind of put a break on that bond they
have and you know she just tells them to
make priority protecting our friends
from the two rivers and um you know i'm
reading this as she you know that land
knows about she's going to see so on and
that she has this side relationship
business relationship with but she
doesn't want land knowing that she's
also in love with her and sleeping with
her i'm sure that's why she does the
masking but we see that is what that
mirror from the last episode i was
asking about is now it's like this magic
mirror something you see from like alice
in looking glass that travels her to see
swan but where there's so much important
dialogue is in this scene with so on and
moraine and swan reiterates the dragon
will defeat the dark one or join him no
matter how many dragons there are right
so moraine says i'll kill them myself
before i will let him have them and swan
says good now we don't know if moraine
really means that or she's just saying
that to keep swan happy and not doubting
her intentions but swan's telling her of
the dream she's having at the dark ones
at the eye of the world he's barely
hanging on to his power but getting
stronger every day we can destroy him if
we go now so that's why there's this
like huge movement to them going into
the way gate later which we'll get to
but this is where marines like we would
be sentencing the other four to certain
death if they're not all you know the
dragon and swan says maybe maybe not but
moraine says who becomes between the
dragon the dark one will die so this is
so important because it says a lot about
moraine's character that she has said
that statements in all the prophecies
it's consistent right that that's just
basically what they take as truth but
later on when he gwen asked her at the
way gate you know what's gonna happen to
whoever's not the dragon she's like you
know we're not certain so it's a very
serious white lie it's not a super light
because there is some yeah still
uncertainty because it is just a
prophecy but you know it's a lie
nonetheless and i'm sure that's going to
come up later on between the two river
group and moraine we also learn here
when leandra is confronting moraine and
on to her about her spending time with
these friends of naive that she says i
will tell the red sisters we both know
what they will do talking about that she
knows that leandro is seeing a man on
the side in north harbor someone who
supposedly hates men so that's
interesting and it shows to how
seriously the red sisters take that that
they would hurt the man in that
situation so it's like they both got a
little dirt on each other here
but i do love again this conflict
between and this you know relationship
seesaw battle between leandrin and
moraine so we see moraine brings aguain
and naive to so on here and i love the
moment when sawan says i've been told
you're the most powerful channeler we
have seen in years naive almeria but at
that moment the wayne thought she was
talking about hers her smile perks up
and then she's like shocked to hear it's
actually naive because again they still
don't know iguain can channel but
there's some good writing here and good
important dialogue with sewing where
she's like the wheel doesn't care if
you're young and afraid the wheel calls
you to this whether you can bear it or
not the last battle is coming what any
of us wants now is meaningless so these
are important lines to throw into
because it's going to be reasons to sell
how we're convinced that all these two
rivers folk except one would actually go
through with this and go through the way
gate it's like almost manipulation in a
way because can we trust all these
things that people say about the
wheelers again there's just these false
statements being made we'll see and
remembering two characters like swan and
moraine you know they at the end of the
day are going after what they really
want their agenda you know and i think
the good of them will be yes they're
doing it for a good cause to stop the
dark one but how are they getting away
with it and how are they doing it and
again it makes it more of a great
character marine by her lying here about
not being sure what happens to the ones
that aren't the dragon now before we
even go that way gate scene though there
was a really good scene here where they
actually show moraine swears on this
oath rod over oath of being exiled and
not coming back to the tower and she can
never return unless so on calls her back
so this was great acting by rosamund and
sophie here because their facial
expressions are saying so much more than
what's actually being said because we're
just hearing the oath but you know
they're able to still put on a front to
all the sisters and still show that
emotion of heartbreak and love for each
other i thought that was really really
good and letting actors that are great
do their thing so i think what's going
to really excite fans of the show is the
band back together here at this way gate
and you know we learned that going right
to the eye of the world and that this is
where the dark zone prison is where he
was trapped by the last dragon at the
cost of almost everything one of you
will finish a job you started in your
past life she says so lines like this
get someone like me who hasn't read the
book really pumped i think people you
know i could see the other side of this
where book readers aren't really
enjoying the show as much um because you
you lose that mystery and suspense and
like what does that mean that's exciting
we're like you already know
so
that's why i didn't read the books
before this and i kind of wanted just to
go in a fresh face because i actually
regret when i read books before the show
i like reading them after for that
reason but you know we'll see maybe i'll
start reading the book soon because
there's so many books and if there's
going to be so many seasons i'm not
gonna be able to read the books and
until what i'm like 50 so but this stuff
as a someone hasn't read the books
really excites me i'm like okay this is
awesome like what it where are we going
with this and when they open that way
gate it looks like you know something
straight the lord of the rings with the
mordor there but the big shocker here is
when matt's like uh is it too late to
change my mind you know so when they're
going into the way gate he doesn't go in
he's like effort you know he stays back
so this is a nice nice cliffhanger one
because they're we got the crew back
together and they're going in the way
gate and two because matt is the big
variable here who didn't go again if we
can get a confirmation that he was
gentled because that would be something
too we have to look into how matt's
gonna be acting now as a result of that
or if it was just literally straight up
some kind of channeling power that you
know moraine used to just get the dark
power and to back into that blade please
someone cleared up and that maybe is
annoying because i don't think i'm an
idiot here right you're an idiot like it
was a little not totally clear to
someone who hasn't read the books like i
would have just assumed it was gentling
if rand didn't just act so you know
nonchalant about it after because he was
so protective before and worried about
that but we'll see but i'm giving this
episode an 8.8 again this is the third
episode of giving an 8.8 it's what's
coming to my mind every time i just
think it's been consistently solid i
hope it gets that nine level and goes to
the ceiling this show can have but yeah
i think i've liked literally all three
episodes the same here in a row i really
enjoyed this this is a slower one but
this is clearly the big setup one where
all scenes are having a great purpose
moving this story forward there's no
throwaway scenes the acting was great
across the board here and we got to let
these two actresses of rosamund and
sophie kind of steal the show here and
show why they've been in this game for a
while and they're they're great acting
chops so it was exciting to watch that
but it's really exciting to see where
this is going next and remember these
are the first six episodes they sent to
critics so we'll see now they've been
holding episode seven i'm sure it's a
big one and again there's going to be
probably some really shocking stuff
happening now we're going to be in a new
environment here so i'm excited to see
what's going to happen but let me know
what you guys think i read every comment
i try to respond as many as i can and
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of the real
time it helps me in so many ways if you
just subscribe you have no idea i'd be
forever grateful to you and please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and if you love what i do here i'd
really appreciate if you become a member
today you'll get exclusive perks and
it'll help me do this full time one day
i'm truly grateful to all of you and
i'll see you next week